YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Google Cloud offers
a wealth of managed
services and serverless
options for your workloads.
But many mission
critical services
use compute
infrastructure directly
and run on Google
Compute Engine instances.
How can we improve observability
for those workloads?
Today, I'm going to show you
how to use the Cloud Operations
agent to do just that.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
First, what are agents,
and why do we need them?
Here is an example of an
infrastructure summary
dashboard for a project
with a few GCE VMs in it.
Notice that we're not
getting any data about how
our instances are using memory.
That's because the
VM hypervisor only
knows how much memory
is allocated to each VM,
not how much of the
allocated memory
the VM is actually using.
This is just one example
of data that can only
be gathered by a process
running in the guest VM,
such as an agent.
There are other
benefits of running
the Ops Agent inside the VM.
It monitors your VM
instances without the need
for any additional
configuration after the install.
It exposes many additional
metrics beyond memory,
and gives you better visibility
to CPU, disk, and network
performance.
And the Ops Agent unifies
gathering of metrics
and logs into a single agent.
If you've been using
Google Cloud for a while,
you're probably familiar
with the Legacy monitoring
and logging agents.
However, at this
point, the Ops Agent
should be used in all cases.
Now that we've covered
the benefits of agents,
let's have a look at how
to install the Ops Agent.
I'm going to show
you how to install
the agent in three ways.
First, we'll install
the agent on a single VM
using local commands.
Then I'll show you how to
install it on a fleet of VMs
by using Agent policies.
And finally, we'll
automate Agent installation
using Terraform.
Let's get into it.
From the project
dashboard, let's go
to monitoring dashboards.
Select the VM
Instances dashboard.
Here, we can see that there's
a VM without any agents on it.
Let's SSH.machine.
Once the SSH connection
is established,
run the commands to download
and install the Ops Agent.
We'll link to the documentation
that has the up to date
command in the episode notes.
After some time, you'll see an
installation succeeded message
from the Cloud Ops Agent.
At this point, we can
go back to our dashboard
and confirm that the VM is
reporting as having the latest
version of the Agent installed.
We can then go to
the VM detail screen
and see that we're getting
agent metrics for that VM,
including memory utilization
and details of CPU usage.
So that's an easy way
to install the Cloud Ops
Agent on a single
virtual machine
by using an SSH connection
and installing the Agent
through the command line.
That was easy enough.
Now that the Agent
is installed, let's
have a look at all
the additional data
it's gathering from our VM.
Let's go to our VM
instances and select our VM.
The observability
tab is a single place
to see monitoring and logging
data collected for this VM.
In the Metrics section,
we can see lots of data,
like memory and
disk utilization.
This is just some
of the information
that's being collected by
our Agent running on the VM.
The Processes
section shows what's
running on the VM and
resource utilization of all
the various processes.
Again, this information is
only available by having
an Agent on the VM.
The Memory section shows us how
memory is being used by the VM.
And finally, the Log section
will show us all the logs
being collected from the VM.
We can open these
in Logs Explorer
to better understand where
each of these is coming from.
So that's how all the
additional data being gathered
by the Agent is collected
in a single place
and made easy for you to use.
The Ops Agent collects
a lot of valuable data.
But how can we install it at
scale across our VM fleet?
Let's have a look at
automating the installation
and maintenance of the Ops
Agent with agent policies.
Let's start on the VM
instances dashboard.
Here, we see that we have
multiple VMs with no Agent
installed on them.
We can install an
Agent on all of them
at once by using
an Agent policy.
Let's have a look
at an example of how
to do that using G Cloud.
We'll post a link to the details
of the command in the episode
notes.
But here's an example that
will require installing the Ops
Agent and all the
instances in the specified
zone that match the operating
system and version filter.
Note that you'll have to
enable the relevant APIs
in your project in
order for this to work.
Again, refer to
the documentation
for those details.
After some time, the operation
will report a success.
We can then go back
to our dashboard
and see that the VMs that match
our operating system filter
and reside in the zone we
specified for the policy
have the latest version of
the Agent installed on them.
We can go to the details
for one of the VMs
and confirm that we're getting
Agent information there.
So that's how you can use
Agent policies to ensure
that the Cloud Ops Agent is
installed and automatically
upgraded across a VM fleet.
Using Agent policies to
automate Agent installation
and maintenance is much more
scalable and error proof
than doing it manually.
But even entering
commands like this
is still prone to
input and human error.
Let's have a look at how to
turn Agent policy configuration
into code with Terraform.
Let's start by defining our
Agent policy using Terraform.
The Agent rule
section will define
which Agent we want to install,
and whether we want to enable
auto upgrading for it.
The group labels, OS
types and zones filters,
will define which VMs are
subject to the policy.
To create the policy, first
issue the Terraform validate
command to make sure
your code is correct.
Once it's validated,
use the Terraform
apply command to create
your Agent policy
and confirm that the
operation is successful.
Once the Apply
command is finished,
run the G Cloud describe command
to validate that the policy has
been successfully created.
Finally, verify that the
policy has been applied,
and that the Agent has been
installed on the instances that
are subject to the policy.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered the Ops Agent, how
it differs from the Legacy
monitoring and logging agents,
manual and automated Agent
installation, and the data
that the Agent provides
to help you improve the
observability if your service
is running on GCE.
I hope this helps you
find issues in your VMs
faster and keep
your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.